I know that you did all these different
projects then Mean Girls comes along yes
and there was a lot of well because
there was a lot that happened before
Mean Girls you were known
definitely like Freaks and Geeks while
it was like a mind-blowing experience
just because it was also new I didn't
like
feel connected to anything I was just
all overwhelming right it wasn't fun it
was just like I can't believe I'm doing
this yeah and I did a few episodes of it
and every episode felt like that and
then sometimes I think like that some
actors only have that experience like
they only have oh people were sort of
nice and it was fine but I didn't like
bond with anybody and I didn't become
like homies with the makeup like they
don't have the full experience well what
I consider to be the full experience and
I think it would be a really bad
job if you only got that version of it
right
because so much of it is like you build
these really intense relationships with
so many people throughout you know every
job maybe you keep like one or two
friends as you move on but like it is I
couldn't the main like oh I couldn't
work in an office thing is I couldn't
imagine not having that
like full-on we are related to each
other we are in love with each other and
now I'll never see you again I need that
weird right it's like it's like being in
I mean I shouldn't say this but it's
Akin in some way uh to
um being in the trenches with some
people like it feels it feels like we're
in this we got to make this work
together and then these bonds form and
it is silly because I realize I'm
describing making television shows and
making sketch comedy or in your case you
know making movies and making TV shows
but it is similar when the greatest part
of it is we're all in this together this
show is in half an hour we gotta do this
we're scared but we're also excited and
you go through that for a number of
years and when I
see
writers and people I've worked with over
the years in the 90s and 2000s and I
just I get emotional and because I think
you were there with me we went through
some crazy stuff yeah it still feels
that way totally and it's like a lot of
the fires that you're putting out let's
say right before going on and doing your
show like it's something that you can't
really fully explain to anybody else who
isn't there who isn't like boots on the
ground and so it does it bonds you and
then like the saying the abrupt goodbye
it took me I guess that's the one
difference is like you do these you did
the same show forever you stuck around
with these people but for me it was like
you have these experiences and then you
really do
like depart this family and I don't know
a single actor certainly not any that
I'm friends with that don't have like
severe abandonment issues and like we
just go and do this to ourselves all the
time like it's wild you know what's
funny we always choose
the thing that we fear most I as a kid
and it's documented because I would talk
about and I actually wrote uh the writer
EB white a letter telling him I was
wanting to do something and maybe be a
writer but that I was very afraid of
criticism and he wrote me back and this
is in 1980 so one of my like 16 years
old and I
know that my nightmare was what's the
thing I care about the most being funny
what would terrify me the terrify me the
most to be up in front of people trying
to be funny and have it not work
I would rather be burned with acid than
have that happen
what did I choose to do yeah
but isn't it impressive that you did
that with your life like you faced the
thing that scared you and yeah you
always have to like put it in context
like no it's not as impressive as like X
Y and Z we're just entertainers or
pieces of [ __ ] don't worry don't worry
we hate ourselves but it is like you
know we're like releasing the thing
that's scary so you said so you said and
do you think this is something that is
true you and other actors is abandonment
issues yeah I mean that's been my
experience for sure right and then is it
something you had your your whole life I
mean yes I mean I know my mom died and
that's when it happened and then and you
were quite young 13 yeah damn but then
like you see all these and I think it
was especially painful at the beginning
because when you're doing especially
like young people high school things for
example when I did a bunch of those
there's this whole social element to it
I'm very happy to have graduated from
this to be honest I aged out of it
because it used to be like okay we're in
Canada for two months and we're going to
work together but we're also going to be
best friends and we have to go out every
single night together and if you don't
go out then you're left out and it's
like this whole social element to it
which is exhausting and then you're
convinced you're going to be best
friends forever and you never are like
you put those relationships you like put
them in the real world and they fizzle
and die except for like maybe one or two
and the same thing with like romantic
relationships like this is this is true
love you have to like learn that a few
times I feel like that's a pretty
Universal thing like then as soon as
you're like not living in a hotel room
with like nothing no responsibility is
whatsoever no distractions nothing
nothing but the people I know who still
hold on to that and there are very few
now that we're grown-ups and people have
families and stuff but like it's never
going to be the same you accept that
it's never going to be the same it was
interesting with with Fleischmann
because Taffy who wrote the book and the
show is her first experience doing a
television show and she's experiencing
all of that for the first time like on
the last day of work like how emotional
that was last day of shooting like but
then what happens and how do we stay
close and how do we keep this going yeah
is often the refrain yeah is this was an
amazing experience we all came together
and we did this yep and then
um the site that always made me sad is
you know all the times that we traveled
our show anywhere there'd be these you
know week shows in San Francisco
amazing set built that recreates the
Golden Gate Bridge and I can come out
and walk on it and and enter the you
know and we do a week of shows there and
remotes and we're up all night and it's
adventures and the minute the show's
over
and you do the last one they start
tearing it all apart and throwing it
into trucks and driving it back to New
York City and that happened I saw that
happen like 25 times
with different shows that we traveled to
different parts of the country and I was
bereft I was in shock like no no that
was
we just like touched the face of God
just had this amazing experience
together and then it's just done so I
know what you're talking about it's a
horrible feeling but you do get used to
it it's like a callous forms and so for
Taffy seeing it with her for the first
time and I just had to be like it's not
going to continue this is it like as bad
as it feels now it doesn't it's not
going to feel better you're just gonna
maybe have another fun experience
hopefully in the future but like this is
dead
there's nothing that I can say to you
other than the truth which is like it
feels bad but most of us have been doing
this for so long we're used to the
feeling and so yeah couldn't you lie to
her just a little bit Yeah
like this is it you've peaked sorry how
is taffy now is she okay yeah but
there's still I mean we're still in it
you know like especially with this roll
out like the old school week by week
episodes coming out it's still happening
but not for much longer you know a few
more weeks that I'll call and be like
now it's really over so it's it sucks
like I do feel for her and the the
premiere was in New York and for many
reasons it was such a celebration uh
like it felt the first time like post
like truly post pandemic like it was a
in Carnegie Hall and a Tavern on the
Green and I hadn't been to a big
Premiere in so long and she kept saying
like it's like my bat mitzvah and it
really was the happiest night of her
life and it was so fun it was genuinely
fun and those Premier parties are never
fun like they're always just kind of
work and I'm always in her ear like
they're never fun like this you know
it's probably never going to be fun like
this again the whole time it's good to
have you around you're all right I like
it what do you like on the holidays this
is probably our last Christmas as a
family the tree was a pagan symbol it's
but it is Fleischmann was one of those
lucky things where like everybody in the
cast was
nice everybody came like very prepared
all these things that don't happen every
time everybody bonded it really felt
like a family and everybody says that
and it rarely actually feels like a
family family but this did to the point
where Taffy gave a speech at the
premiere and she said she thanked her
sons and her her husband Claude at the
end and everybody I mean the thunderous
Applause for Claude because everybody in
that room knew like we took your wife
away and you had to hold it down and
like the first time you do a show I
can't imagine anything crazier and
everybody knew Claude and everybody knew
how he stepped up in the greatest way
and everybody it felt like genuinely
like the warmth and the room for this
show I have never experienced anything
like that and I think it is because of
Taffy coming in all green and
bright-eyed and like this is amazing and
it's nice to have somebody remind you
like oh actually this is amazing yeah it
is uh
my
experience I saw it at SNL when I'd been
there for a while and was really still
Blown Away by it but I'll never forget
when Adam Sandler showed up for the
first time as a kid all he kept doing
was coming back like oh this is the best
this is the best oh my god did you know
and again that same kind of thing like
these snacks are free and I thought I've
always been drawn to
that energy I love that energy because I
think the biggest challenge and I'm not
just talking about show business I mean
in any career the biggest challenge is
how do I stay young and I don't mean how
do I look young but how do I just keep
that sense of wow this is fun yeah which
is you know you have to work at it it's
like stomach crunches or something you
just have to do it you really keep
bringing up the maps yeah I don't think
you've we got it let's see a wonderful
ass there we go
um
the sound blarp isn't heard much but
when I take my shirt off you'll hear
three blarps as different chunks of
abdominal fats settle down by my ass
oh come on ladies out there you getting
hot how does your abdominal effect get
to your ass yeah it falls yeah so it's
back abdominal it's like pendulum swings
back the twist the legs thank you oh
yeah thank you yeah it happens he saw me
come out of the ocean so it's like
you're like swing dancing with your body
that's a beautiful way yeah about it
it's like that German that Berlin film
swing dance which is all about people
German what an improbable film I think
it takes place like during World War II
and there are Nazis but kids are Germans
are swing dance and you're like no no
yeah you're impressive swing dancers but
maybe opposed this regime
[Applause]
Hitler's driving by in a Mercedes-Benz
and he hears the the swing music and he
goes in and he sees them all and he
decides to be a better person oh that's
nice Yeah dance God bless them yeah